This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you grew up speaking a language other than English, you probably reached for words in your native tongue without even thinking about it. Cochely, it's Verkse, Mal de Porco. Olma polma. There are phrases in every language that are deeply evocative and often untranslatable. If you're studying a new language, you might discover these phrases not in your textbooks, but when you're hanging out with friends.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。如果你是在非英语环境中长大的，你可能在不经意间就会脱口而出母语中的词汇。Cochely，Verkse，Mal de Porco，Olma polma。每种语言中都有一些含义深远且往往难以翻译的短语。如果你正在学习一门新语言，你可能不是在教科书里，而是在和朋友闲聊时发现这些短语的。
My name is Jennifer Diakone Cruz. Jennifer moved to Japan for graduate school. And I ended up living there for 10 years. It took just one week of living in Japan for Jennifer to pick up an important new term. Mendo Kusai. Here's what she says it means. It's this phrase that describes something between, I can't be bothered, or I don't want to do it, or I recognize the incredible effort
我叫詹妮弗·迪亚科内·克鲁兹。詹妮弗为了读研搬到了日本。我最终在那里住了10年。詹妮弗在日本生活仅一周，就学会了一个重要的新词：Mendokusei。这就是她所说的意思。这个短语描述了一种介于“我不想麻烦”或“我不想做”之间的状态，或者是我意识到某件事需要付出巨大的努力，
that goes into something even though it shouldn't be so much of an effort. Still don't have a clear picture? Imagine this. It's a Sunday afternoon and it's raining outside and you're at home and your pajamas all nice and cuddly and maybe you're watching Netflix or something. And you suddenly get a craving for potato chips and you realize that you have none in the kitchen and there's nothing else you really want to eat.
尽管它本不该需要那么多努力。还是没有清晰的概念吗？想象一下：这是一个周日的下午，外面下着雨，你待在家里，穿着睡衣，感觉很舒适，也许正在看Netflix之类的节目。突然，你很想吃薯片，却发现厨房里没有，而且也没有其他特别想吃的东西。
And maybe the convenience store, the shop, is really not that far away. Maybe it's even less than 100 meters away, but you just can't bring yourself to even throw your coat on over your pajamas and put your boots on and go outside and walk those 100 meters because somehow it breaks the coziness. And it's just too much of an effort and you can't be bothered to do it even though it's such a small thing. So it's Mendok's Eye. The moment she heard it, Jennifer realized Mendocci was incredibly useful. It describes this feeling so perfectly in such a wonderfully packaged and capsulated way
也许便利店离这儿真的不远。可能不到100米，但你就是无法让自己穿上外套，套上靴子，走到外面走那100米，因为这会破坏那种舒适感。这实在太费劲了，即使是这么小的一件事，你也懒得去做。所以这就是Mendokusei。詹妮弗一听到这个词，就意识到Mendokusei非常有用。它以一种极其美妙、浓缩的方式完美地描述了这种感觉，
and it rolls off the tongue and you can just throw it out. Mendocci, I just don't want to do it. If you're bilingual or you're learning a new language, you get what Jennifer experienced. The joy of discovering a phrase that helps you perfectly encapsulate a feeling or an experience. The phrase brings an entire world with it, its context, its flavor, its culture. Today we explore the many facets of this idea. Languages are not just tools to describe the world, they are ways of seeing the world. The categorization that language provides to you becomes real, becomes psychologically real.
而且它朗朗上口，你可以随口说出来。Mendokusei，我就是不想做。如果你是双语者或者正在学习一门新语言，你就能理解詹妮弗的感受。发现一个能完美概括某种感觉或经历的短语，这种快乐是无与伦比的。这个短语带来了一个完整的世界，包括它的语境、风味和文化。今天，我们来探讨这个理念的多个层面。语言不仅仅是描述世界的工具，它们还是看待世界的方式。语言为你提供的分类法会变得真实，变得心理上真实。
This week on Hidden Brain, the boss has a new boy, the sister of the boss, how the languages we speak shape the way we think The horse's a lot more boy. The susur is the most important thing. How the languages we speak shape the way we think, and why the words we use are always in flux. My guess today is, why don't I let her introduce herself? The way to say my name properly in Russian is Kalerea Ramandovna Buraditskaya So I don't make people say that well, that's kind of you
本周的《Hidden Brain》，老板有个新男孩，老板的妹妹，我们所说的语言如何塑造我们的思维方式。马有更多的男孩。苏苏尔是最重要的东西。我们所说的语言如何塑造我们的思维方式，以及为什么我们使用的词汇总是在不断变化。我今天的嘉宾是……为什么不让她自己介绍一下呢？用俄语正确说出我名字的方式是Kalerea Ramandovna Buraditskaya，所以我不会强迫人们那样说，那太客气了。
In the English speaking world she goes by Lara Boroditsky Lara is a cognitive science professor at the University of California, San Diego long before she began researching languages as a professor, foreign languages loom large in her life. When she was 12, her family came to the United States from the Soviet Union. My family is Jewish and we left as refugees. I decided it was very important for me to learn English because I had always been a very verbal kid and I'd always always the person who recited poems in front of the school and you know, led assemblies and things like that.
在英语世界，她叫拉拉·博罗迪茨基。拉拉是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的认知科学教授。早在她作为教授开始研究语言之前，外语就在她的生活中占据了重要地位。12岁时，她的家人作为难民从苏联来到美国。“我的家庭是犹太人，我们作为难民离开。我决定学习英语对我来说非常重要，因为我一直是个很健谈的孩子，我总是那个在学校前面背诵诗歌、主持集会之类的人。”
And to arrive in a new place where you can't tell a joke and can't express an idea, oh, it's just really painful because you feel like your whole self is hiding inside and no one can see it. And so I set myself the goal that I would learn English in a year and I wouldn't speak Russian to anyone for that whole first year. And I did that. Lera now tries to understand languages spoken all over the world. She once visited an Aboriginal community in Northern Australia and found the language they spoke
“来到一个新地方，却无法讲笑话，无法表达想法，这真的很痛苦，因为你会觉得整个自我都藏在里面，没人能看见。”所以我给自己定下目标，要在一年内学会英语，并且在那第一年里不和任何人说俄语。我做到了。拉拉现在试图理解世界各地使用的语言。她曾访问澳大利亚北部的一个原住民社区，发现他们所说的语言
forced her mind to work in new ways. Just saying hello was difficult. I had this wonderful opportunity to work with my colleague Alice Gabi in this community called Pumperau in on Cape York. And what's cool about languages like the language is spoken in Pumperau is that they don't use words like left and right and instead everything is placed in cardinal directions like north-south-east and west. So the way you say hi in a cooktire is to say which way are you heading? And the answer should be north-north-east in the far distance. How about you? So why literally to get past hello you have to know which way you're heading. In fact, speakers of languages like this have been shown to orient extremely well,
迫使她的思维以新的方式运作。仅仅打个招呼都很困难。“我有幸与我的同事爱丽丝·加比在约克角一个叫庞普劳的社区工作。像庞普劳语这样的语言的酷之处在于，它们不使用‘左’和‘右’这样的词，而是将一切都置于东南西北等方位中。所以，在库克泰尔语中打招呼的方式是问：‘你要去哪儿？’答案应该是：‘去远处的东北偏北方向。你呢？’所以，字面上讲，要越过‘你好’这一关，你必须知道你要去哪个方向。”事实上，使用这类语言的人被证明定位能力极强，
much better than we used to think humans could. We always knew that certain species of animals had abilities to orient that we thought were better than human, and we always had some biological excuse for why we couldn't do it. We'd say, oh, well, we don't have magnets in our beaks or in our scales or whatever. But it turns out humans can stay oriented really, really well, provided that their language and culture requires
比我们过去认为人类能做到的要好得多。我们一直知道某些动物物种具有我们认为优于人类的定向能力，而且我们总是为自己做不到这一点找一些生物学上的借口。我们会说：“哦，好吧，我们的喙或鳞片里没有磁铁之类的东西。”但事实证明，只要语言和文化要求，人类可以保持非常、非常好的定向感。
them to keep track of this information. I understand that if you're in a picnic with someone from this community and you notice an ant climbing up someone's left leg, it wouldn't make a lot of sense to tell that person, look there's an ant on your left leg. Well there may not be a word for left to refer to a left leg in a lot of languages there isn't, so you might say there's an ant on your northwest leg. The fun example I give my students is imagine playing the Hoki Boki in a language like this.
“我明白，如果你和这个社区的人一起野餐，注意到一只蚂蚁爬上某人的左腿，告诉那个人‘看，你左腿上有只蚂蚁’是没有意义的。好吧，很多语言中可能没有指代左腿的‘左’字，所以你可能会说‘你西北方向的腿上有只蚂蚁’。”我给学生举的有趣例子是，想象一下用这种语言玩“霍基-波基”舞。
There's no left leg or right leg. As soon as you move the leg, it becomes a different leg. So you may start with moving your southwest leg in, but then you have to move your northeast leg out. You do the hoki-boki and you turn yourself around. That's what it's all about. So I find that I'm often directionally and navigational challenged when I'm driving around and I often get my east-west mixed up with my left-right for reasons I have never been able to fathom. So but if I understand correctly I would be completely at sea if I visited this Aboriginal community in Australia because I have often absolutely no idea where I am or where I'm going. Well, you would be at sea at first, but actually it's something that's not so hard to learn.
没有左腿或右腿。一旦你移动那条腿，它就变成了另一条腿。所以你可能先移动你的西南腿，但接着你必须移动你的东北腿。你跳着霍基-波基，转过身来。这就是它的全部意义。所以我发现我在开车时经常在方向和导航上遇到困难，而且我经常把东西南北和左右搞混，原因我一直无法理解。但是，如果我理解得没错，如果我访问这个澳大利亚原住民社区，我会完全迷失方向，因为我经常完全不知道我在哪里，或者我要去哪里。嗯，起初你会迷失方向，但实际上，这并不是很难学。
Many people have this intuition that, oh, I could never learn that. I could never survive in a community like this. But actually, that's exactly how people in those communities come to stay oriented is that they learn it, right? You have to do it in order to fit into the culture and to speak the language. I had this cool experience when I was there. I was trying to stay oriented because people were treating me like I was pretty stupid for not being oriented and that hurt. So I was trying to keep track of which was which. And one day I was walking
很多人有这种直觉：“哦，我永远学不会那个。我永远无法在这样的社区生存。”但实际上，这正是那些社区的人保持定向的方式，他们学会了它，对吧？为了融入文化并说这种语言，你必须这样做。我在那里有过一次很酷的经历。我当时试图保持定向，因为人们觉得我因为没有定向感而很笨，这让我很受伤。所以我试图记住哪个是哪个。有一天我走着，
along and I was just staring at the ground. And all of a sudden I noticed that there was a new window that had popped up in my mind. And it was like a little bird's-eye view of the landscape that I was walking through and I was a little red dot that was moving across the landscape. And then when I turned this little window stayed locked on the landscape, but it turned in my mind's eye. And as soon as I saw that happen, I thought, oh, this makes it so much easier. Now I can stay oriented and I kind of sheepishly confess this to someone there. I said, you know, this weird thing happened. I saw this bird's eye view and I was little red dot.
我只是盯着地面。突然，我注意到我的脑海中弹出了一个新窗口。它就像是我所经过景观的鸟瞰图，而我是一个在景观中移动的小红点。然后当我转弯时，这个小窗口锁定在景观上，但在我的心眼中转动。一旦我看到这种情况发生，我想：“哦，这让事情变得容易多了。”现在我可以保持定向了，我有点羞怯地向那里的人承认了这一点。我说：“你知道，发生了件奇怪的事。我看到了这个鸟瞰图，而我是一个小红点。”
And they said, well, of course, how else would you do it? Of course that's right. What was remarkable for me was that my brain figured out a really good solution to the problem after a week of trying, right? So I think it's something that is quite easy for humans to learn if you just have a reason to want to do it. Time is another concept that is also central to the way we see and describe the world. And you've conducted experiments that explore how different
他们说：“嗯，当然，不然你怎么做呢？”当然是这样。对我来说，了不起的是，在尝试了一周后，我的大脑为这个问题找到了一个非常好的解决方案，对吧？所以我认为，只要你有理由想要这样做，这对人类来说是相当容易学习的。时间是另一个概念，它也是我们看待和描述世界方式的核心。你进行过实验，探讨了不同的
conceptions of time and different languages shape the way we think about the world and shape the way we think about stories. How so? One thing that we've noticed is this idea of time, of course, is very highly constructed by our minds and our brains. So you can't see time, you can't touch time, you can't smell or taste time. But it is a completely crucial part of the human experience. Of course, you also can't experience anything outside of time. It is the very fabric, the very core of your experience. So the question for us has been, how do we build these ideas? It's not just about how we think about time. It's how we think about anything that's abstract, that's beyond our physical senses. And one thing that we've noticed is that around the world, people rely on space to organize time. So, for example, for English speakers, people who read from left to right, time tends to flow from left to right. So, earlier things are on the left. Later things are on the right.
时间观念和不同的语言如何塑造我们对世界的思考方式，以及我们对故事的思考方式。怎么说呢？我们注意到的一件事是，时间这个概念当然是由我们的思想和大脑高度构建的。所以你看不见时间，摸不着时间，闻不到或尝不出时间。但它是人类体验中完全至关重要的一部分。当然，你也无法体验时间之外的任何事物。它是你体验的本质，核心。所以我们的问题一直是：我们是如何构建这些想法的？这不仅仅是关于我们如何思考时间。这是关于我们如何思考任何抽象的、超出我们感官的东西。我们注意到的一件事是，在世界各地，人们依靠空间来组织时间。例如，对于从左到右阅读的英语使用者来说，时间往往从左到右流动。所以，较早的事情在左边，较晚的事情在右边。
If I give you a bunch of pictures to lay out and say, this is telling you some kind of story and they're disorganized. When an English speaker organizes those pictures, they'll organize them from left to right. But if I give that same story to a Hebrew and Arabic speaker, they would organize it from right to left. That is the direction of writing in Hebrew and Arabic going from right to left. But time doesn't have to flow with respect to the body. So to go back to the example we were just talking about people who don't use
如果我给你一堆图片让你排列，并说“这在讲一个故事”，而它们是杂乱的。当英语使用者整理这些图片时，他们会从左到右整理。但如果我把同样的故事给希伯来语和阿拉伯语使用者，他们会从右到左整理。这就是希伯来语和阿拉伯语从右到左的书写方向。但时间不一定要相对于身体流动。所以回到我们刚才谈到的例子，那些不使用
words like left and right, when I gave those picture stories to cooktire speakers who stories to cooktire speakers who use North-South-Eastern West, they organize the cards from East to West. And so what that means is if someone was sitting facing South, they would lay out the story from left to right. But if they're sitting facing North, they would lay out the story from right to left. And if they're facing East, they would make the carts come toward them, toward the body. So that's an example of how languages and cultures construct how we use space to organize time, to organize this very abstract thing. That's otherwise kind of hard to get our hands on and think about. If languages are shaped by the way people see the world, but they also shape how people see the world, what does this mean for people who are bilingual?
“左”和“右”这类词的人，当我把这些图片故事给使用东南西北的库克泰尔语使用者时，他们会从东到西整理卡片。这意味着，如果有人面朝南坐着，他们会从左到右排列故事。但如果他们面朝北坐着，他们会从右到左排列故事。如果他们面朝东，他们会把卡片朝向自己，朝向身体。这就是语言和文化如何构建我们如何利用空间来组织时间，来组织这个原本很难把握和思考的抽象事物的例子。如果语言是由人们看待世界的方式塑造的，但它们同时也塑造了人们看待世界的方式，这对双语者意味着什么？
If you can speak more than one language, does this mean that you're also simultaneously and constantly shifting in your mind between different world views? That's a wonderful question. One possibility for bilinguals would be that they just have two different minds inside, right? So one one skull but two different minds and you shift from one to the other. Another possibility is that it's a fully integrated mind and it just incorporates ideas and distinctions from both languages or from many languages if you speak more than two. What turns out to be the case
如果你能说不止一种语言，这是否意味着你在脑海中也在同时不断地在不同的世界观之间切换？这是一个很好的问题。对于双语者来说，一种可能性是他们脑子里有两个不同的思想，对吧？所以一个头骨里有两个不同的思想，你从一个切换到另一个。另一种可能性是，这是一个完全整合的思想，它只是结合了两种语言的观点和区别，如果你会说两种以上的语言，就是多种语言。事实证明，
is that it's something in between that bilinguals don't really turn off the languages they're not using when they're not using them. So even if I'm speaking English, the distinctions that I've learned in speaking Russian, for example, are still active in my mind to some extent. But they're more active if I'm actually speaking Russian. So bilinguals are kind of this in-between case where they can't quite turn off their other languages, but they become more prominent, more salient when you're actually speaking the language or surrounded by the language. So I want to talk about a debate that's raised in your field for many years. There are many scholars who would say,
情况介于两者之间，双语者在不使用某种语言时，并不会真正关闭它。所以即使我在说英语，我在俄语中学到的区别在某种程度上仍然在我的脑海中活跃。但如果我真的在说俄语，它们会更活跃。所以双语者是一种中间情况，他们不能完全关闭他们的其他语言，但当你真正说这种语言或被这种语言包围时，它们会变得更加突出、更加显著。所以我想谈谈你所在领域多年来引发的一场辩论。有很多学者会说，
look, yes, you do see small differences between speakers of different languages, but these differences are not really significant. They're really small. How big are the differences that we're talking about and how big do you think the implications are for the way we see the world? Yeah, so there are some differences that are as big as you can possibly measure. For example, when we started talking about navigation, that's an example where a five-year-old in a culture that
“看，是的，你确实看到了不同语言使用者之间的小差异，但这些差异并不显著。它们真的很小。”我们谈论的差异有多大？你认为这对我们看待世界的方式有多大的影响？是的，有些差异大到你无法测量。例如，当我们开始谈论导航时，这是一个五岁的孩子在一种
uses words like North-South East and West can point southeast without hesitation. They know which ways which. And very competent adults of our culture can't do that. So that's a measurement difference of 100% of performance. There's not a bigger difference you could find than 100% of the measurement space. You also see huge differences in other domains, like number. So, some languages don't have number words.
使用东南西北这类词的文化中，可以毫不犹豫地指出东南方向。他们知道哪个方向是哪个。而我们文化中非常有能力的成年人却做不到这一点。所以这是一个100%表现的测量差异。你找不到比100%测量空间更大的差异了。你在其他领域也能看到巨大的差异，比如数字。所以，有些语言没有数字词。
And if you don't have a word for exactly seven, it actually becomes very, very hard to keep track of exactly seven. And that is an example of a simple feature of language, number words, acting as a transformative stepping stone to a whole domain of knowledge. Of course, if you can't keep track of exactly seven, you can't count. You're also not going to do algebra, you're not going to do trigonometry, you're not going to do any of the things that are seen as a foundation of our technological society. So that again is a huge difference. So in terms of the size of differences, there are certainly effects that are really,
如果你没有一个确切表示“七”的词，实际上要准确记住“七”就变得非常非常困难。这是一个简单的语言特征——数字词——作为通往整个知识领域的变革性垫脚石的例子。当然，如果你不能准确记住“七”，你就不能计数。你也不会做代数，不会做三角学，也不会做任何被视为我们技术社会基础的事情。所以这又是一个巨大的差异。因此，就差异的大小而言，确实存在非常、
really big. But things can be important, not just because they're big, they can be small differences, but important in other ways. So for example, grammatical gender. Because grammatical gender applies to all nouns in your language, that means that language is shaping the way you think about everything that can be named by a noun. Well, that's an incredibly large set of things. So that's a very broad effect of language. So to give you a very quick wrap up is that some effects are big, but even when the effects aren't big, they can be interesting or important for other reasons either because they're very broad or because they apply to things that we think are really important in our culture. Languages orient us to the world. They shape our place in it. When we come back,
非常大的影响。但事物之所以重要，不仅仅是因为它们大，它们可能是微小的差异，但在其他方面很重要。例如，语法性别。因为语法性别适用于你语言中的所有名词，这意味着语言正在塑造你对所有可以用名词命名的事物的思考方式。嗯，那是一个极其庞大的事物集合。所以这是语言的一个非常广泛的影响。所以简单总结一下，有些影响很大，但即使影响不大，它们也可能因为其他原因而有趣或重要，要么是因为它们非常广泛，要么是因为它们适用于我们认为在文化中非常重要的事物。语言引导我们走向世界。它们塑造了我们在其中的位置。当我们回来时，
we dig further into the way that gender works in different languages and the pervasive effects that words can play in our lives. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're speaking today with cognitive science professor L Lara Boroditsky, about language. In many languages, nouns are gendered. La forchette, le couteau. Diyacca, de mantel. Melaka, s'kin.
我们将进一步挖掘性别在不同语言中是如何运作的，以及词汇在我们生活中可能产生的普遍影响。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们与认知科学教授拉拉·博罗迪茨基讨论语言。在许多语言中，名词是有性别的。La forchette，le couteau。Diyacca，de mantel。Melaka，s'kin。
The word chair is feminine in Italian. La saidier. But masculine in German. Deir stul. I ask Lara how describing the word chair or the word bridge as masculine or feminine changes the way that speakers of different languages think about those concepts.
“椅子”这个词在意大利语中是阴性的，La sedia。但在德语中是阳性的，Der Stuhl。我问拉拉，将“椅子”或“桥”描述为阳性或阴性，如何改变了不同语言使用者对这些概念的思考方式。
Actually, one of the first people to notice or suggested this might be the case was a Russian linguist Roman Yachapsin, and he started by asking Russian speaking students to personify days of the week. So act, act like Monday. Pani Ziyanek. Or act like Wednesday. Sridida. And Russian is a language that has grammatical gender. Different days of the week have different genders for some reason. And what he noticed was that when people were trying to act like Monday, they would act like a man. Pani Del Nik. And when they were trying to act like Monday, they would act like a man, and when they were trying to act like Wednesday, they would act like a woman, which
实际上，最早注意到或提出这可能是这种情况的人之一是俄语语言学家罗曼·雅各布森，他首先要求讲俄语的学生将一周中的日子人格化。所以，表现得像周一。Ponedelnik。或者表现得像周三。Sreda。俄语是一种有语法性别的语言。出于某种原因，一周中的不同日子有不同的性别。他注意到，当人们试图表现得像周一（阳性）时，他们会表现得像个男人。而当他们试图表现得像周三（阴性）时，他们会表现得像个女人，这
accords with grammatical gender in Russian. And so he suggested it might be the case that the arbitrarily assigned grammatical genders are actually changing the way people think about these days of the week and maybe all kinds of other things that are named by nouns. So, we've done a lot of studies looking at how speakers of Spanish and German and Russian actually think about objects that have opposite grammatical genders. Take the word bridge, if it's feminine in your language, you're more likely to say that
与俄语中的语法性别相符。因此他提出，任意分配的语法性别实际上可能正在改变人们对这些日子的思考方式，甚至可能改变所有用名词命名的其他事物。所以，我们做了很多研究，观察西班牙语、德语和俄语的使用者实际上是如何思考具有相反语法性别的物体的。以“桥”这个词为例，如果它在你的语言中是阴性的，你更有可能说
bridges are beautiful and elegant. And if the word bridge is masculine in your language, you're more likely to say that bridges are beautiful and elegant. And if the word bridges masculine in your language are more likely to say that bridges are strong and long and towering, these kind of more stereotypically masculine words. And of course, you always have to wonder, well, could it be that speakers of these different languages are actually seeing different kinds of bridges? So maybe they're saying bridges are beautiful and elegant, not because they're grammatically feminine in the language, but because the bridges they have are, in fact, more beautiful and elegant.
桥是美丽而优雅的。如果“桥”这个词在你的语言中是阳性的，你更有可能说桥是坚固、漫长而高耸的，这些更具刻板印象的阳性词汇。当然，你总是会怀疑，好吧，会不会是这些不同语言的使用者实际上看到了不同种类的桥？所以也许他们说桥是美丽而优雅的，不是因为它们在语言中是语法阴性的，而是因为他们拥有的桥实际上更美丽、更优雅。
And so, to address that question, what we do is we bring English speakers into the lab, and we teach them grammatical genders in a new language that we invent. We call this language, Gumbuzzi. And we teach them, for example, to say that bridges and apples and all kinds of other things have the same prefix as women. So the word for the is different for women than for men. And it's also different for forks versus spoons and things like that.
为了解决这个问题，我们把英语使用者带到实验室，教他们一种我们发明的新语言中的语法性别。我们称这种语言为Gumbuzzi。我们教他们，例如，说桥、苹果和各种其他东西与女性有相同的前缀。所以“定冠词”这个词对女性和男性是不同的。对于叉子和勺子之类的东西也是不同的。
And what we find is that if you teach people that forks go with men grammatically in a language, they start to think of forks as being more masculine. And if you teach them that forks go with women, they start to think that forks are more feminine. The categorization that language provides to you becomes real, becomes psychologically real. One study that I love is a study that asked monolingual speakers of Italian and German, and also bilingual speakers of Italian and German, to give reasons for why things are the grammatical genders that they are. So for example, if the word chair is masculine in language, why is that?
我们发现，如果你教人们叉子在语法上与男性相关，他们开始认为叉子更具阳性。如果你教他们叉子与女性相关，他们开始认为叉子更具阴性。语言为你提供的分类法会变得真实，变得心理上真实。我喜欢的一项研究是，要求意大利语和德语的单语使用者，以及意大利语和德语的双语使用者，给出为什么事物具有它们所具有的语法性别的原因。例如，如果“椅子”这个词在某种语言中是阳性的，为什么会这样？
If you're a monolingual speaker of one of these languages, you're very likely to say that the word chair is masculine because chairs are in fact masculine. So these speakers have internalized this idea from their language and they believe that it's right. They believe that their language reflects the true structure of the world. If you ask bilinguals who've learned two languages and now they know that some genders disagree across the two languages, they're much less likely to say that it's because chairs are intrinsically masculine. They're more likely to say, well, it's a formal property of the language. They're
如果你是这些语言之一的单语使用者，你很可能会说“椅子”这个词是阳性的，因为椅子实际上就是阳性的。所以这些使用者已经从他们的语言中内化了这个想法，并且他们相信它是正确的。他们相信他们的语言反映了世界的真实结构。如果你问那些学过两种语言、现在知道某些性别在两种语言中不一致的双语者，他们不太可能说这是因为椅子本质上是阳性的。他们更有可能说：“嗯，这是语言的一种形式属性。”他们
more likely to see through this little game that language is played on them. I understand that there's also been studies looking at how artists who speak different languages might paint differently depending on how their languages categorize concepts like a mountain or death. Yeah, so we did an analysis of images in art store. This is a database with millions of art images. We looked at every personification and allegory in art store and asked, does the language that you speak
更有可能看穿语言对他们玩的这个小游戏。我了解到，还有研究观察了说不同语言的艺术家如何根据他们的语言如何分类像“山”或“死亡”这样的概念而以不同的方式绘画。是的，我们对Artstor中的图像进行了分析。这是一个拥有数百万艺术图像的数据库。我们查看了Artstor中的每一个人格化和寓言，并询问：你所说的语言
matter for how you paint death depending on whether the word death is masculine or feminine in your language. And to our surprise, 78% of the time, we could predict the gender of the personification based on the grammatical gender of the noun in the artist's native language. So if the word for death was masculine in your language, you were likely to paint death as a man. And if it was feminine and you're likely to paint death as a woman. The size of this effect really quite surprised me because I would have thought at the outset that artists are these iconoclasts. They're supposed to be painting something very personal. But in fact, they were reflecting this little quirk of grammar, this little quirk of their language.
是否对你如何描绘“死亡”有影响，取决于“死亡”这个词在你的语言中是阳性还是阴性。令我们惊讶的是，78%的情况下，我们可以根据艺术家母语中名词的语法性别来预测人格化的性别。所以如果“死亡”这个词在你的语言中是阳性的，你很可能会把死亡描绘成一个男人。如果它是阴性的，你很可能会把死亡描绘成一个女人。这种影响的大小确实让我很惊讶，因为我起初会认为艺术家是那些打破常规的人。他们应该画一些非常个人的东西。但事实上，他们反映了语法中的这个小怪癖，他们语言中的这个小怪癖。
In some cases, carving those quirks of grammar into stone because when you look at statues that we have around liberty and justice and things like this, they have gender. It's lady liberty and lady justice. Those are quirks of grammar literally in stone. Our conversation made me wonder about what this means on a larger scale. There's a speaker of a language like Spanish who has to assign gender to so many things, end up seeing the world as more gendered. Lara said there's still a lot of research to be done on this, but she told me a story about a conversation she had with a native speaker of
在某些情况下，将这些语法怪癖刻在石头上，因为当你观察我们周围关于自由和正义的雕像时，它们是有性别的。那是自由女神和正义女神。这些是刻在石头上的语法怪癖。我们的谈话让我思考这在更大范围内意味着什么。一个像西班牙语这样必须给许多事物分配性别的语言使用者，最终是否会以更性别化的方式看待世界？拉拉说这方面还有很多研究要做，但她给我讲了一个她与一位
Indonesian. I spoke really terrible Indonesian at the time, so I was trying to practice, and I was telling this person about someone I knew back in America, and they asked me all kinds of questions about them. And then question 21 was, is this person a man or a woman? And I thought, wow, first of all, it would be almost impossible to have a conversation like that in English where you hadn't already revealed the gender of the person because you have to use he or she. But also I started wondering, is it possible
印尼语母语者交谈的故事。“我当时印尼语说得很烂，所以我试图练习，我告诉这个人关于我在美国认识的一个人，他们问了我各种关于他们的问题。然后第21个问题是：‘这个人是男人还是女人？’我想，哇，首先，在英语中几乎不可能进行那样的对话，因为你还没透露那个人的性别，因为你必须使用‘他’或‘她’。但也开始怀疑，有没有可能
that my friend here was imagining a person without a gender for this whole time that we've been talking about them, right? So when I ask you to say, imagine a man walking down the street. Well, in your imagery, you're going to have some details completed and some will be left out. So for example, you might not imagine the color shirt that he's wearing or the kinds of shoes that he's wearing. That kind of detail may not appear. So, it's easy to think, oh, I could imagine someone without thinking explicitly about what they're wearing. But can you imagine someone without imagining their gender? Right. And so, for me, that
我的这位朋友在这整个谈话过程中一直想象着一个没有性别的人，对吧？所以当我让你说‘想象一个男人走在街上’时，在你的意象中，你会完成一些细节，而另一些会被遗漏。例如，你可能不会想象他穿的衬衫颜色或他穿的鞋子种类。那种细节可能不会出现。所以，很容易认为‘哦，我可以想象某人而不明确思考他们穿着什么。’但你能想象某人而不想象他们的性别吗？对。所以对我来说，那个
question was born in that conversation of, are there some languages where it's easier to imagine a person without the characteristics of gender filled in. So you can think about an ungendered person in the same way that I might think about a person without a specific age or a specific height or a specific color shirt. I think it's a really fascinating question for future research. So this begs the question, if you were to put languages on something of a spectrum where you have languages like Spanish or Hindi where nouns are gendered and languages like English where many nouns are not gendered but pronouns are gendered and on the other end of this spectrum
问题诞生于那次谈话中：是否有些语言更容易想象一个没有性别特征的人？所以你可以像思考一个没有特定年龄、特定身高或特定衬衫颜色的人一样，思考一个无性别的人。我认为这是一个非常迷人的未来研究课题。所以这就引出了一个问题：如果你把语言放在某种光谱上，一边是有名词性别的语言，如西班牙语或印地语，另一边是许多名词没有性别但代词有性别的语言，如英语，而在光谱的另一端
languages like Finnish or Persian where you can have a conversation about someone without actually mentioning their gender, it would seem surprising if this did not translate at some level into the way people thought about gender in their daily activities, in terms of thinking about maybe even who can do what in the workplace that could this affect the way sexism conscious or unconscious operates in our world? It's certainly possible. I think language can certainly be a contributor into the complex system of our thinking about gender. There's been a little bit of research from economists actually looking at this. So they've compared gender equality, gender parity norms
是像芬兰语或波斯语这样的语言，你可以和某人交谈而不提及他们的性别，如果这不在某种程度上转化为人们在日常活动中对性别的思考方式，那似乎会令人惊讶，就思考可能甚至谁能在工作场所做什么而言，这会影响性别歧视（有意识或无意识）在我们世界中的运作方式吗？这当然是有可能的。我认为语言当然可以成为我们思考性别这一复杂系统的一个促成因素。实际上，经济学家已经对此进行了一些研究。所以他们比较了性别平等、性别均等规范，
from the World Health Organization, which ranks countries on how equal access to education, how equal pay, how equal representation in government is across the genders. And they have correlated this with gender features in the language, just like the ones you were talking about. And they suggest that differences across languages do, in fact, predict some of these measures of gender equality across countries. I understand there's been some work looking at children and that children who speak certain languages
来自世界卫生组织，该组织根据性别在教育机会、同工同酬、政府代表性方面的平等程度对国家进行排名。他们将此与语言中的性别特征进行了关联，就像你刚才谈到的那些。他们认为，不同语言之间的差异确实预测了各国在性别平等方面的某些指标。我了解到，还有一些研究观察了儿童，说某些语言的儿童
are actually quicker to identify gender and their own gender than children who are learning other languages and other cultures. Yeah, that's true. So there are these wonderful studies by Alexander Giorro where he asked kids learning Finnish, English, and Hebrew as their first languages. Basically, are you a boy or a girl?
实际上比学习其他语言和其他文化的儿童更快地识别性别和他们自己的性别。是的，那是真的。所以亚历山大·吉奥罗有一些很棒的研究，他要求学习芬兰语、英语和希伯来语作为第一语言的孩子。基本上是问：“你是男孩还是女孩？”
This takes kids a little while to figure out, and he had all kinds of clever ways to ask these questions. For example, he might take a bunch of pictures of boys and girls and sort them and say, okay, this is a boy, it goes in this pile, a girl goes in this pile and then he would take a polaroid of the kid and say, well, this is you, which pile do you go in? And what he found was kids who are learning Hebrew, this is a language that has a lot of gender loading in it, figured out whether they were a boy or a girl, about a year sooner than kids learning
这需要孩子花一点时间才能弄清楚，他有各种聪明的方法来问这些问题。例如，他可能会拿一堆男孩和女孩的照片并对它们进行分类，说：“好吧，这是一个男孩，它放在这堆里，一个女孩放在这堆里。”然后他会给孩子拍一张宝丽来照片，说：“好吧，这是你，你属于哪一堆？”他发现，学习希伯来语的孩子（这是一种性别负载很重的语言）弄清楚自己是男孩还是女孩的时间，比学习
finish, which doesn't have a lot of gender marking in the language. Of course, eventually the Finnish kids also figured it out because language isn't the only source of that information, otherwise it would be quite surprising for the Finns to be able to continue to reproduce themselves. But somehow they've managed not just by randomly bumping into each other. But it's a lovely example of how language can guide you to discover something about the world that might take you longer to discover if you didn't have that information in language. Languages seem to have different ways of communicating agency.
芬兰语的孩子（语言中没有太多性别标记）要早一年左右。当然，最终芬兰孩子也弄清楚了，因为语言不是该信息的唯一来源，否则芬兰人能够继续繁衍后代会相当令人惊讶。但不知何故，他们不仅通过随机碰撞做到了这一点。但这是一个可爱的例子，说明语言如何引导你发现关于世界的一些东西，如果你没有语言中的那些信息，可能需要更长时间才能发现。语言似乎有不同的方式来传达主体性。
So in English, I might say that Sam broke the flute, but I understand that in Spanish this would come out quite differently. Yeah, lots of languages make a distinction between things that are accidents and things that are intentional actions. So for example if Sam grabbed a hammer and struck the flute in an anger, that would be one description like Sam broke the flute. But if he just bumped into the table and it happened to fall off the table and break and it was an accident, then you might be more likely to say the flute broke or the flute broke itself or it so happened to Sam that the
所以在英语中，我可能会说“萨姆打破了长笛”，但我了解到在西班牙语中，这会有很大的不同。是的，很多语言在意外和有意行为之间做出了区分。例如，如果萨姆抓起一把锤子愤怒地敲击长笛，那将是一种描述，比如“萨姆打破了长笛”。但如果他只是撞到了桌子，它碰巧从桌子上掉下来摔碎了，这是一个意外，那么你可能更倾向于说“长笛碎了”或“长笛自己碎了”，或者“萨姆碰巧让
flute broke. You would give a different description to Mark that it was not intentional. In English, actually quite weirdly, we can even say things like, I broke my arm. In a lot of languages, you can't say that because unless you were crazy and you went out looking to break your arm and you succeeded, right?
长笛碎了”。你会给出不同的描述来标记它不是故意的。在英语中，实际上很奇怪，我们甚至可以说“我弄断了我的胳膊”。在很多语言中，你不能那样说，因为除非你疯了，出去找着要弄断自己的胳膊并且成功了，对吧？
You would have to say something like, my arm got broken or it so happened to me that my arm is broken. It's not something that you typically go up trying to do intentionally. And there are consequences for how people think about events, what they notice when they see accidents. So for example, English speakers, because they're very likely to say he did it or someone did it, they are very good at remembering who did it, even if it's an accident,
你必须说类似“我的胳膊断了”或“我碰巧让我的胳膊断了”。这不是你通常会故意去做的事情。人们对事件的思考方式、他们在看到意外时注意到的东西是有后果的。例如，英语使用者，因为他们很可能说“他做了”或“某人做了”，他们非常擅长记住是谁做的，即使是意外，
whereas speakers of language like Spanish might not be quite as good at remembering who did it when it's an accident, but they're better at remembering that it was an accident. So you have speakers of two different languages look at the same event and come away with different memories of what happened because of the structure
而像西班牙语这样的语言使用者在意外发生时可能不太擅长记住是谁做的，但他们更擅长记住这是一个意外。所以你有两种不同语言的使用者看着同一个事件，却因为他们语言的结构
of their languages in the way they would normally describe that. Around the world, we often hear that many languages are dying and there are a few mega languages that are growing and expanding in all kinds of ways. What do you think the implications are? If you buy the idea that languages are a very specific and unique way of seeing the world of perceiving reality, what are the implications of so many languages disappearing during our time? Well, I think it's a terrible tragedy. Each language comprises the ideas that have been worked out in a culture over thousands of generations.
以及他们通常描述事件的方式，而对发生的事情留下了不同的记忆。在世界各地，我们经常听到许多语言正在消亡，而有少数几种超级语言正在以各种方式增长和扩张。你认为这意味着什么？如果你相信语言是一种看待世界、感知现实的非常具体和独特的方式，那么在我们这个时代有这么多语言消失意味着什么？嗯，我认为这是一个可怕的悲剧。每种语言都包含了文化中经过数千代人磨练出来的思想。
And that is an incredible amount of cultural heritage and complexity of thought that disappears whenever a language dies. MIT linguist Ken Hale, a renowned linguist, said that every time a language dies, it's the equivalent of a bomb being dropped on the Louvre. That's how much cultural heritage is lost. And some people would say it's a lot more because it's, you know, irrecoverable and not reduplicated elsewhere. And there are all kinds of interesting, useful eye-opening ideas that exist in all of the world's languages. So I think it's an incredible tragedy that we're losing all of this linguistic
每当一种语言消亡时，那都是令人难以置信的文化遗产和思想复杂性的消失。麻省理工学院语言学家肯·黑尔，一位著名的语言学家，曾说每当一种语言消亡，就相当于在卢浮宫投下了一枚炸弹。这就是损失了多少文化遗产。有些人会说损失更多，因为它是不可恢复的，在其他地方没有重复。而且在世界所有的语言中，存在着各种各样有趣、有用、令人大开眼界的想法。所以我认为我们正在失去所有这些语言
diversity, all of this cultural diversity, because it is human heritage. It's testament to the incredible ingenuity and complexity of the human mind that all of these different perspectives on the world have been invented. And it's sad that we're not going to be able to make use of them and learn them and celebrate them. Lara Borditsky is a cognitive science professor at the University of California San Diego. Lara, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. If you have teenagers or work closely with young people, chances are you've been mystified by their conversations or even annoyed.
多样性、所有这些文化多样性是一个令人难以置信的悲剧，因为这是人类的遗产。这是人类思维令人难以置信的独创性和复杂性的证明，所有这些对世界的不同视角都被发明了出来。令人难过的是，我们将无法利用它们、学习它们并庆祝它们。拉拉·博罗迪茨基是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的认知科学教授。拉拉，非常感谢你今天加入《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢你的邀请。如果你有十几岁的孩子或与年轻人密切工作，你很可能对他们的谈话感到困惑，甚至感到恼火。
Young people have always used language in new and different ways and it's pretty much always driven older people crazy. All of the likes and, like, literalize might sometimes great on your nerves. But John McQuarrer says, the problem might be with you, not with the way other people speak. John is a professor of English and comparative literature at Columbia University. He's also the author of the book, Words on the Move, Why English Won't and Can't sit still, Like, Literally. why English won't and can't sit still like literally. John McWater, welcome to Hidden Brain.
年轻人总是以新的和不同的方式使用语言，这几乎总是让老年人发疯。所有的“像”和“字面上的”有时可能会让你感到厌烦。但约翰·麦克沃特说，问题可能出在你身上，而不是别人说话的方式。约翰是哥伦比亚大学英语和比较文学教授。他也是《Words on the Move, Why English Won't and Can't sit still, Like, Literally》一书的作者。为什么英语不会也不能像字面上那样静止不动。约翰·麦克沃特，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。
Thank you. Many of us have dictionaries at home or at work, John, and you say that dictionaries in some ways paint an unrealistic portrait of a language. They give us a sense that the meanings of words are fixed when, in fact, they're not. Yeah, dictionaries are wonderful things, give us a sense that the meanings of words are fixed when in fact they're not. Yeah, dictionaries are wonderful things, but they create an illusion that there's such
谢谢。约翰，我们许多人在家里或工作中都有字典，你说字典在某些方面描绘了一幅不切实际的语言图景。它们让我们觉得词义是固定的，而事实上并非如此。是的，字典是好东西，它们让我们觉得词义是固定的，而事实上并非如此。是的，字典是好东西，但它们制造了一种错觉，即存在着
thing as a language that stands still. When really, it's the nature of human language to change. Each generation hears things and interprets things slightly differently from the previous one. I mean, just in terms of even sounds changing, in the way that you put words together changing bit by bit. And there's never been a language that didn't do that. I love this analogy you have in the book where you mention how, you know, thinking that a word has only one meaning is like looking at a snapshot taken at one point in a person's
一种静止不变的语言。而实际上，人类语言的本质就是变化。每一代人听到的东西和理解的东西都与前一代人略有不同。我的意思是，仅仅就发音的变化，以及你把词语组合在一起的方式一点点改变而言。从来没有一种语言是不这样变化的。我很喜欢你在书中提到的那个类比，你说认为一个词只有一个意思，就像看着一个人在某一点上拍的快照，
life and saying, this photograph represents the entirety of what this person looks like. Exactly. It's as if you saw a person, I'm not going to say it for, because then the person is growing up. And if I use that analogy, then it seems like I'm saying that language grows up where it moves towards something or it develops. Imagine you meet somebody there 39, and you take their picture. And then 10 years later, when they're 49 and you take their picture. And then 10 years later, when they're 49, you say, well, that picture of you at 39 is what you really are and whatever has happened to you since then,
然后说，这张照片代表了这个人的全部长相。没错。这就好像你看到一个人，我不会说“为了”，因为那样的话，这个人就在成长。如果我用那个类比，那么看起来我好像是在说语言在成长，它朝着某个方向发展或演变。想象一下，你遇到了一个39岁的人，你给他们拍了张照片。然后10年后，当他们49岁时，你给他们拍了张照片。然后10年后，当他们49岁时，你说，好吧，你39岁时的那张照片才是真正的你，而从那以后发生在你身上的一切，
is some sort of disaster, something that shouldn't have happened. How come you aren't exactly the way you were 10 years ago? That's the way words are too, but it's so hard to feel that. Partly because our brains are on writing, as I say in the book, we can't help as literate people thinking that the real language is something that sits still with letters written all nice and pretty on a page that can exist for hundreds of years. But that's not what language has ever been, only a couple hundred languages. If you want to be conservative about it, a hundred languages are written in any real way, and then there are 6,800 others. Language is something
都是某种灾难，是不应该发生的事情。你怎么会和10年前完全不一样呢？词语也是如此，但很难感受到这一点。部分原因是我们的大脑依赖书写，正如我在书中所说，作为识字的人，我们不禁认为真正的语言是静止不动的，字母写在纸上既漂亮又整洁，可以存在几百年。但语言从来都不是那样的，只有几百种语言。如果你想保守一点，有几百种语言是以真正的方式书写的，然后还有6800种其他语言。语言是
that's spoken, and spoken language, especially always keeps changing. It's inherent. One of the points you make in the book, of course, is that the evolution of words and their meanings is what gives us this flowering of hundreds or thousands of languages, mistakes and errors, are what turned Latin into French. Yes, that's exactly true. What we think of today as a word undergoing some odd development or people using some new construction is exactly how Latin turned into French. It's exactly how old English turned into modern English. And I don't think any of us are thinking that it's a shame that we're not using the language of
口头的，而口头语言，尤其是总是不断变化的。这是内在的。你在书中提出的观点之一，当然是词语及其意义的演变赋予了我们成百上千种语言的繁荣，错误和失误正是将拉丁语变成法语的原因。是的，这完全正确。我们今天认为的一个词正在经历某种奇怪的发展，或者人们使用某种新的结构，这正是拉丁语变成法语的方式。这正是古英语变成现代英语的方式。而且我认为我们没有人会觉得我们没有使用那种语言是一种遗憾。
Bayo Wolf. So I think that nobody would say that they don't think language should change. But what most people mean is that there'll be slang, that there'll be new words for new things, and that some of those words will probably come from other languages. But I don't think that it's always clear to us that language has to change in that things are going to come in, that we're going to hear as intrusions, or as irritating, or as mistakes, despite the fact that that's how you get from, say, old person to modern person.
贝奥武夫。所以我认为没有人会说他们不认为语言应该改变。但大多数人指的是会有俚语，会有新事物的新词，而且其中一些词可能会来自其他语言。但我认为我们并不总是清楚语言必须改变，即会有一些东西进来，我们会将其视为入侵，或者令人恼火，或者视为错误，尽管事实上这就是你从，比如说，古代人变成现代人的方式。
And nobody wishes that we hadn't developed our modern languages today from the ancient versions. I want to talk in the second half of our conversation about why the meanings of words change, but I want to start by talking about how they change. Let's start with the word literally. It turns out, as you point out, that in common usage, literally means the opposite of literally. The second button literally makes or breaks the shirt. Look at it. It's too high.
而且没有人希望我们今天没有从古代版本发展出我们的现代语言。我想在谈话的后半部分讨论为什么词义会发生变化，但我想先从它们是如何变化的开始谈起。让我们从“literally”（字面上）这个词开始。事实证明，正如你指出的那样，在常用用法中，“literally”的意思与“literally”相反。第二个扣子“literally”（简直/确实）决定了衬衫的成败。看看它。它太高了。
Dr. Harris, you are literally the meanest person I've ever met. In the first days, literally making or literally making or literally I'm not sure if you're literally the meanest person. Yeah, and it irritates people, but there's a different way of seeing literally. If you take literally in what we can think of as it's earliest meaning, the earliest meaning known to us is by the letter. And so somebody says something literally. Somebody takes a point literally.
哈里斯博士，你“literally”（简直）是我见过最刻薄的人。在最初的日子里，“literally”制造或“literally”制造或“literally”我不确定你是否“literally”是最刻薄的人。是的，这让人恼火，但有一种看待“literally”的不同方式。如果你把“literally”看作我们可以认为是它最早的含义，我们所知的最早含义是“按字母顺序”。所以有人“literally”地说某事。有人“literally”地接受一个观点。
Well, if you have a word like that, and if it's an intensifier of that kind, you can almost guess that literally is going to come to mean something more like just really. So what happens is that once literally comes to feel like it means really, people start using it in figurative constructions such as, I was literally dying of thirst. Now many people hear that and they think, well, that's no good because now literally can mean it's opposite. But we have plenty of words like that in English where it doesn't bother us at all. For example, if you take seeds and put them in the ground, that's one thing.
好吧，如果你有这样一个词，如果它是那种程度的强化词，你几乎可以猜到“literally”最终会意味着更像“真的”。所以发生的事情是，一旦“literally”开始感觉像意味着“真的”，人们就开始在比喻结构中使用它，例如，“我‘literally’渴死了”。现在很多人听到这个，他们会想，好吧，这不好，因为现在“literally”可以意味着它的反义词。但在英语中，我们有很多这样的词，它们根本不会困扰我们。例如，如果你把种子放进土里，那是一回事。
But if you see the watermelon, nobody assumes that you're taking seeds and putting them in the watermelon and you're taking them out. Those are called contrainins and literally has become a new contrainim, it should be thought of as fun. One of the things I found really interesting is that the evolution of words and language is constant. So new words are as likely to evolve as old ones. So, LOL was an internet abbreviation, meaning laugh out loud or laughing out loud, but LOL and common users today doesn't necessarily mean historical laughter. No, because LOL was an expression, it was a piece of language, and so you knew that its meaning was going to change. The only question was in which way. And
但如果你看到西瓜，没有人会假设你正在把种子放进西瓜里，然后你又把它们取出来。这些被称为反义同形词，“literally”已经成为一个新的反义同形词，它应该被认为是很有趣的。我发现非常有趣的一点是，词语和语言的演变是恒定的。所以新词和旧词一样容易演变。所以，LOL是一个互联网缩写，意思是“大声笑”或“正在大声笑”，但LOL在今天的普通用户中并不一定意味着历史上的大笑。不，因为LOL是一种表达，它是语言的一部分，所以你知道它的意思会改变。唯一的问题是以哪种方式。而且
then ended up becoming less direct reflection of hearty laughter than an indication of the kind of almost subconscious laughter that we do in any kind of conversation that's meant as friendly. It can be almost counterintuitive to listen to how much giggling and laughing you do. in ordinary, actually rather plain exchanges with people. It's part of a general running indication that everything's okay between you and the other person, just like one's expected to smile a little bit in most interactions. So, LOL starts out as meaning hardy, hardy, hard, but then it becomes something more abstract. But the reason that it seems so elusive
最终变得不再是爽朗大笑的直接反映，而是一种我们在任何友好谈话中都会做的近乎潜意识的笑声的表示。听听你在普通、实际上相当平淡的交流中发出多少咯咯笑声和笑声，这甚至可能有点违反直觉。这是你和对方之间一切都好的一般性持续表示的一部分，就像大多数互动中人们被期望微笑一点一样。所以，LOL开始时意味着爽朗的大笑，但后来它变得更加抽象。但它看起来如此难以捉摸的原因
is because we don't really think about the quote-unquote meaning of things like our conversation easing laughter. As someone who spends a lot of his time listening to language evolve, John hears a lot of slang. He's a defender of language on the move, but I wanted to know if there were things that irritated even him. But I wanted to know if there were things that irritated even him. Oh yeah, I'm a human being, and so even though I insist that there is no scientific basis for rejecting some new word or some new meaning or some new construction, I certainly have my visceral biases. And so for example, can I get a hamburger can I get some chicken I've always found that a very
是因为我们并没有真正去思考像我们谈话中那种轻松笑声的所谓“意义”。作为一个花很多时间倾听语言演变的人，约翰听到了很多俚语。他是语言发展的捍卫者，但我想知道是否有连他都感到恼火的事情。但我想知道是否有连他都感到恼火的事情。哦，是的，我是个人，所以即使我坚持认为拒绝某个新词或某种新含义或某种新结构没有科学依据，我当然也有我本能的偏见。所以例如，“我可以要一个汉堡吗”、“我可以要一些鸡肉吗”，我一直觉得这是一种非常
grating way to ask for something at a store it seems kind of elliptical like would it be possible that I obtained and then if you are going to be that elliptical why use the casual word get and it sounds a little bit abrupt and grabby like you're going to get something instead of being given. All of these are very subjective things. It's not necessarily may I please have but may I have I'll have but not can I get a I find it just vulgar for reasons that as you can see I can't even do what I would call defending. It's just how I feel and we're all gonna have feelings like that and when I listen to people having their peas I don't think stop it
在商店里索要东西的刺耳方式，它看起来有点省略，就像“我获得……是否可能”，然后如果你要那么省略，为什么要用随意的词“get”（得到）？而且它听起来有点突兀和贪婪，就像你要去“得到”某样东西，而不是被给予。所有这些都是非常主观的事情。不一定是“我可以请给我吗”，而是“我可以要吗”、“我要这个”，但不是“我可以得到一个……”，我觉得它很粗俗，原因正如你所见，我甚至无法做到我所说的辩护。这只是我的感觉，我们都会有那样的感觉，当我听到人们发出他们的“pee”时，我不会想“停下来”。
But what I am thinking is you should realize that even if you don't like it There's nothing wrong with it in the long run because for example Jonathan Swift Didn't like it that people were saying kissed instead of kiss it and rebuked instead of rebuked. He didn't like that people were shortening the words. How does that sound now? We don't want to be like that. All right, I think it might be time for me to confess one of my pet peeves.
但我想到的是，你应该意识到，即使你不喜欢它，从长远来看，它也没有什么错，因为例如乔纳森·斯威夫特不喜欢人们说“kissed”而不是“kiss it”，说“rebuked”而不是“rebuked”。他不喜欢人们缩短词语。现在听起来怎么样？我们不想那样。好吧，我想现在是我承认我的一件心头大患的时候了。
It has to do with the word momentarily. Growing up, I understood this word to mean for a very short time, as in John McWater was momentarily surprised. But I find that people now usually use the word to mean very soon, as in we're gonna board the plane momentarily. The dictionary says both uses are correct. But you know John something nauseate me every time I hear the word used wrong and after listening to you, I realize I might have to finally give in. When we come back I'm going to ask you about why languages change and whether there are hidden rules such shape, why some words are more likely to evolve than
它与“momentarily”（片刻地）这个词有关。在成长过程中，我理解这个词的意思是“在很短的时间内”，正如“约翰·麦克沃特感到片刻惊讶”。但我发现人们现在通常用这个词来表示“很快”，正如“我们很快就要登机了”。字典说两种用法都是正确的。但你知道约翰，每次我听到这个词被用错，我都感到恶心，听了你的话，我意识到我可能最终不得不屈服。当我们回来时，我要问你为什么词义会发生变化，以及是否有隐藏的规则塑造了为什么有些词比
others. We'll be back momentarily. Stay with us. I'm Shankar Vidantantham and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you're just joining us, I'm talking to John McWater. He's a professor of English and comparative literature at Columbia University and the author of the book Words on the Move, why English won't and can't sit still, like literally. John, you've noted that humans have been using language for a very long time, but for most of that time, language has been about talking.
其他词更容易演变。我们很快就会回来。请继续关注我们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。如果你刚加入我们，我正在和约翰·麦克沃特交谈。他是哥伦比亚大学英语和比较文学教授，也是《移动的词语：为什么英语不会也不会静止不动，比如literally》一书的作者。约翰，你提到人类使用语言已经很长时间了，但在那段时间的大部分时间里，语言都是关于说话的。
Writing has come along relatively recently. Are the spoken origins of language one reason that words so often seem to be on the move? Yes, Shankar, that's exactly it. Language, as it evolved, was just talking to an extent that can be very hard for we literate people to imagine. There was no way of transcribing an approximation of what people said, and nobody would have thought of doing it. Language was talk. When language was like
书写是相对较近才出现的。语言的口头起源是词语似乎经常处于移动状态的一个原因吗？是的，尚卡尔，正是如此。语言在演变过程中，只是说话，其程度对于我们识字的人来说可能很难想象。没有办法转录人们所说的话的近似值，也没有人会想到这样做。语言就是谈话。当语言像
that, of course, it changed a lot. Fast, because once you said it, it was gone, and if people heard the sounds a little differently and produced them a little differently, if there were new meanings of words very quickly, whatever the original meaning was, wouldn't be remembered. There was no such thing as looking up what it originally meant. And so language changed, just like the clouds in the sky. But then you start writing things down and you're in a whole new land. Because once things are sitting there written on that piece of paper, there's that illusion. And it really is an illusion that what language is is something that sits still. There's a way of speaking right.
那样时，当然，它变化很大。很快，因为一旦你说出来，它就消失了，如果人们听到的声音有点不同，产生的声音也不同，如果词语很快有了新的含义，原来的含义就不会被记住。没有查阅它最初含义这回事。所以语言变了，就像天上的云一样。但后来你开始把事情写下来，你就进入了一个全新的领域。因为一旦事情写在那张纸上，就有了那种错觉。这确实是一种错觉，即语言是静止不动的东西。有一种正确的说话方式。
And the way you speak right is not by speaking the way the people around you in your life speak, but by speaking the way the language is, as it sits there all nice and pretty on that piece of paper where its reality exists. Would it be possible to use what we have learned about how words and languages evolve to potentially write what a dictionary might look like in 50 years or 100 years? You could have fun doing such a thing. The fact is that language change can always go in one of many directions as a chance element to it.
而正确的说话方式不是像你生活中周围的人那样说话，而是像语言本身那样说话，因为它静静地躺在那张纸上，它的现实存在于那里。是否有可能利用我们所学的关于词语和语言如何演变的知识，来潜在地写出50年或100年后字典可能的样子？你可以做这样的事情，会很有趣。事实是，语言变化总是可以向许多方向之一发展，因为它有一个偶然因素。
So you can't know how the words are going to come out, but you can take good guesses. Endings are going to tend to drop off. So if you took a bunch of those tendencies, you could make up, say, the English of 50 years from now. But some of the things would just be complete chance. You would never know, for example, that, give you an example I've actually been thinking about. Women under about 30 in the United States
所以你无法知道词语会变成什么样，但你可以做出很好的猜测。词尾往往会脱落。所以如果你采取一堆这样的趋势，你可以编造出，比如说，50年后的英语。但有些事情将完全是偶然的。你永远不会知道，例如，给你一个我实际上一直在思考的例子。美国30岁以下的女性
When they're excited or they're trying to underline a point putting up at the end of things And so somebody will say well who was it who you thought was gonna give you this present? You And I mean, really it sounds exactly like that. I know Is there or something along the lines of babe and as odd as that sounds I can guarantee you if you watch any TV show with women under a certain age or if you just go out on an American street and listen you'll find that that's a new kind of exclamatory particle that is the most random thing and I would really guess that in a few decades
当她们兴奋或试图强调某一点时，会在事情的结尾加上“……”。所以有人会说，好吧，你以为是谁要给你这个礼物？“你……”。我的意思是，听起来确实是那样。我知道……或者类似“宝贝”的东西，尽管听起来很奇怪，但我可以向你保证，如果你看任何有特定年龄以下女性的电视节目，或者如果你只是走到美国街头去听，你会发现那是一种新的感叹词，这是最随机的事情，我真的会猜在几十年内
men will be doing it too. Those sorts of things tend to start with women. You couldn't have predicted this. I know, uh, move, uh, you can't know, but you can certainly know that if we could listen to people 50 years from now, they'd sound odd. Something new will have started by then. Just like if we listen to people in 1971, they sound odd in that they don't say like as much as we do. That hasn't started then. Imagine how we would sound to them if they could hear us.
男性也会这样做。这类事情往往从女性开始。你无法预测这一点。我知道，呃，移动，呃，你无法知道，但你当然可以知道，如果我们能听听50年后的人们说话，他们听起来会很奇怪。到那时会有新的东西开始。就像如果我们听1971年的人说话，他们听起来很奇怪，因为他们不像我们说那么多“like”。那时还没有开始。想象一下，如果他们能听到我们说话，我们对他们来说会听起来怎么样。
So all this raises a really interesting question. You know, we spend years teaching children about how to use language correctly. As someone who works in media, I often find that people who can write well are often people who know how to think well. So I often equate clarity of writing with clarity of thought. How do you balance the imperative of teaching correct usage, which I think is probably important with the reality that this edifice that you're teaching is constantly crumbling? It's a matter of fashion, pure and simple.
所以这一切提出了一个非常有趣的问题。你知道，我们花几年时间教孩子们如何正确使用语言。作为一个在媒体工作的人，我经常发现那些能写好的人往往是那些知道如何思考好的人。所以我经常把写作的清晰度等同于思维的清晰度。你如何平衡教授正确用法的必要性（我认为这可能很重要）与你所教授的这座大厦正在不断崩塌的现实？这纯粹是时尚问题。
People do need to be taught what the socially acceptable forms are. But what we should teach is not that the good way is logical and the way that you're comfortable doing it is illogical, it should just be, here is the natural way. Then there's some things that you're supposed to do in public because that's the way it is, whether it's fair or not. And you can even teach people to have a little bit of fun with the artifice.
人们确实需要被教导什么是社会可接受的形式。但我们应该教导的不是“好的方式是合乎逻辑的，而你习惯的方式是不合乎逻辑的”，而应该只是，“这是自然的方式”。然后有些事情你应该在公共场合做，因为事实就是如此，无论它是否公平。你甚至可以教人们对这种人为的东西有一点乐趣。
But it's exactly like, it was maybe about 20 years ago, that somebody, a girlfriend I had told me that, if I wore pants that had little vertical pleats up near the waist, then I was conveying that I was kind of past it. That was somehow a dad's fashion and that I should start wearing flat fronted pants. That is utterly arbitrary, that those little slits in American society look elderly. But for various chance reasons, that's what those
但这完全就像，大约20年前，我有一个女朋友告诉我，如果我穿腰部附近有小垂直褶皱的裤子，那么我就在传达我已经“过时”了。那不知何故是爸爸的时尚，我应该开始穿平前裤。那是完全武断的，在美国社会中，那些小缝隙看起来很老。但由于各种偶然的原因，那些
slits came to mean. So I started wearing flat fronted pants. That is exactly why you should say fewer books instead of less books in some situations and yes, Billy and I went to the store rather than the perfectly natural Billy and me went to the store. Sometimes you just have to suck it up but I think that we should learn not to listen to people using natural language as committing errors because there's no such thing as making a mistake in your language if a critical mass of other people speaking your language are doing the same thing. You make the case that concerns over the misuse of language might actually be one of the last places where people can publicly express prejudice and class differences.
缝隙最终意味着什么。所以我开始穿平前裤。这正是为什么在某些情况下你应该说“fewer books”（更少的书）而不是“less books”，是的，“Billy and I went to the store”（比利和我去了商店）而不是完全自然的“Billy and me went to the store”。有时你只需要忍受它，但我认为我们应该学会不要把使用自然语言的人视为犯错，因为如果大量使用你的语言的其他人都在做同样的事情，那么你的语言中就没有“犯错”这回事。你提出了一个观点，即对语言误用的担忧实际上可能是人们可以公开表达偏见和阶级差异的最后地方之一。
And as you point out, it's not just that people feel that a word is being misused, they often feel angry about it. And you think this anger is actually telling. Yeah, I really do. I think that the tone that many people use when they're complaining that somebody says, Billy and me went to the store. It's a little bit in commensurate with the significance of the issue. And I can't help surmising that part of it is that the educated American has been taught and often well, that you're not supposed to look down on people because of gender, because of race, because of ability. But might we allow that there's probably a part of all human beings to look down on people because of gender, because of race, because of ability.
正如你指出的那样，人们不仅觉得一个词被误用了，他们还经常对此感到愤怒。你认为这种愤怒实际上说明了问题。是的，我真的这么认为。我认为许多人在抱怨某人说“Billy and me went to the store”时所使用的语气。这与问题的严重性有点不相称。我不禁推测，部分原因是受过教育的美国人被教导，而且往往教得很好，你不应该因为性别、种族、能力而看不起人。但我们是否可以承认，可能所有人类都有一个部分，因为性别、种族、能力而看不起人。
But might we allow that there's probably a part of all human beings that wants to look down on somebody else? What a cynical thing to say, but that doesn't mean that it might not be true. And if that is true, then the educated person can look down on people who say Billy and me went to the store or who are using literally quote unquote wrong, and condemn them in the kinds of terms that once were ordinary for condemning black people or women or what have you. So I just think that it's something we need to check ourselves for.
但我们是否可以承认，可能所有人类都有一个部分想要看不起别人？这话说得真刻薄，但这并不意味着它可能不是真的。如果这是真的，那么受过教育的人就可以看不起那些说“Billy and me went to the store”的人，或者那些“literally”用错的人，并以曾经用于谴责黑人、女性或其他什么人的那种术语来谴责他们。所以我只是认为这是我们需要自我检查的事情。
It might irritate you slightly to hear somebody say something like, I need less books instead of fewer books. But does a person who says that really deserve the kind of sneering condemnation that you often see? There's a lolier part of our nature that grammar allows us to vent in the absence of other ways to do it that have not been available for some decades for a lot of us. One of the ultimate messages I took from your work is that you know we can choose to have languages that are alive or languages that are dead and dead languages never change and some of us might prefer those but if you prefer life the unpredictability of life then living languages in many ways are much more fun. Language is a parade, and nobody sits at a parade
听到有人说“I need less books”（我需要更少的书）而不是“fewer books”可能会让你稍微恼火。但说这话的人真的值得你经常看到的那种冷嘲热讽的谴责吗？我们本性中有一个更低级的部分，语法允许我们在缺乏其他方式的情况下发泄，而这对于我们许多人来说已经几十年没有了。我从你的作品中得到的一个终极信息是，你知道我们可以选择拥有活着的语言还是死去的语言，死去的语言永远不会改变，我们中的一些人可能更喜欢那些，但如果你喜欢生活，喜欢生活的不可预测性，那么活着的语言在许多方面要有趣得多。语言是一场游行，没有人坐在游行队伍里
wishing that everybody would stand still. If the language stayed the way it was, it would be like a pressed flower in a book, or as I say, I think it would be like some inflatable doll rather than a person. I think that it's better to think of language as a parade, that either you're watching or frankly that you're in, especially because the people are never going to stand still. It's never happened, it's never going to, and if you can enjoy it as a parade instead of wondering why
希望每个人都站着不动。如果语言保持原样，它就像书里压扁的花，或者正如我所说，我认为它就像某种充气娃娃而不是一个人。我认为最好把语言看作一场游行，你要么在看，要么坦率地说你在其中，尤其是因为人们永远不会站着不动。这从未发生过，也永远不会发生，如果你能把它当作一场游行来享受，而不是想知道为什么
people keep walking instead of just sitting on chairs and blowing on their tubos and not moving, then you have more fun. I want everybody to have the fun I'm having. John McQuatter, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you for having me, son. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Ronsang Hero this week is Adam Cole, who wrote and performed our rendition of the
人们一直在走，而不是坐在椅子上吹着大号而不动，那么你会更有趣。我希望每个人都能享受到我正在享受的乐趣。约翰·麦克沃特，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我，尚卡尔。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的“Ronsang Hero”是亚当·科尔，他编写并表演了我们的
Hoki-Poki. Adam is one of those people who's talented in so many different areas, a terrific journalist and thinker, and a gifted musician to boot. Thanks so much for lending us your creative mind, Adam. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Hoki-Poki。亚当是那种在许多不同领域都有才华的人，是一位出色的记者和思想家，也是一位天才的音乐家。非常感谢你借给我们你的创造性思维，亚当。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有用，请尽你的一份力量帮助我们茁壮成长。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。